[Musik]
Russen und Finnen waren mal gute
Nachbarn das ist jetzt vorbei seit
Putins Einmarsch in die Ukraine
beherrschen vor allem Sanktionen und
einreisesperren das Verhältnis im
Grenzgebiet Köder man merkt schon dass
die Russen fehlen denn wir sind so nah
an der Grenze die Russen kamen vor allem
zum Einkaufen in der Stadt hat man viel
russisch gehört jetzt hört man das nicht
mehr
dass der Krieg bald zu Ende ist und
wieder Normalität zurückkehrt das
bezweifeln viele mit denen ich
gesprochen habe
sehr schwer dass die Russen aufgeben es
ist eine Frage von Ehre und von
Unbesiegbarkeit sie sind leidensfähig
und werden eine Niederlage nie
akzeptieren
[Musik]
für die junge Generation zeichnet sich
eine völlig andere Zukunft ab
ich finde es einfach nur schade dass es
immer noch Krieg gibt das wäre es nicht
besser gelernt haben
ich bin unterwegs in Finnland Schweden
und Dänemark und will verstehen wie neue
Mitgliedschaften in der NATO und ein
neuer Krieg in Europa das Leben in
diesen Ländern beeinflussen
Dänemarks Store bellt Brücke über den
Großen Welt überspannt seit 25 Jahren
die Ostsee wie ein gigantisches Tor
allein der Ostteil ist mit einer Länge
von gut 1,6 Kilometern Europas größte
Hängebrücke durchschnittlich 36.000
Fahrzeuge nutzen täglich diese wichtige
Verkehrsader zwischen Skandinavien und
Mitteleuropa
unten drunter transportieren rund 27.000
Schiffe im Jahr Millionen Tonnen von
Fracht mich überrascht dass viele aus
russischen Häfen kommen trotz der
Sanktionen gegen Putins Russland warum
ist das so antworten erhoff ich mir von
denen die die See kennen wie ihre
Westentasche die früher als Kapitäne
selbst zur See fuhren und jetzt ihre
Kollegen lotsen
sie nehmen mich mit zu den großen
Schiffen auf hoher See
Frank Schmidt und Morten green erzählen
was sich seit dem Überfall auf die
Ukraine verändert hat
manche Reedereien haben entschieden den
Sanktionen zu folgen sie arbeiten nicht
mehr mit St Petersburg zusammen Mast zum
Beispiel aber andere Schiffe aus China
oder der Türkei oder Indien die haben
das Geschäft übernommen
also die Summe der Schiffe die hier
unterwegs sind hat sich glaube ich nicht
groß verändert
nach Europa und in die USA dürfen
russische Rohstoffe nicht verschifft
werden durchaus aber in den Nahen Osten
nach Indien oder China solange der
Weltmarktpreis 60 Dollar pro fast nicht
überschreitet darf Russland auch Öl
exportieren wo die Fracht aber am Ende
ankommt scheint völlig offen
[Musik]
Gas Kohle und Öl wird einen Weg finden
das ist die Weltwirtschaft was sie mit
der Fracht machen ob sie sie irgendwo
von einem Schiff auf ein anderes umladen
oder irgendwas mit den Papieren
anstellen oder Öl in Indien verarbeiten
weiß ich nicht
aber indien hat nie Erdöl produziert wie
können sie plötzlich Öl exportieren wenn
sie es nicht irgendwoher bekommen haben
auf 8 Knoten soll die auf den
marshallinsel registrierte Lex ihre
Geschwindigkeit reduzieren damit das
Lotsenboot längsseits gehen kann immer
dabei Franks kleiner Koffer mit dem
aller nötigsten denn Frank ist tagelang
auf See umschiffe zu lotsen der
verbringt ein paar Stunden an Bord bevor
es zum nächsten Schiff geht der Umstieg
jedes Mal ein gewagtes Manöver oben
angekommen treffen Lotsen immer wieder
auf gemischte Besatzungen aus Russen und
Ukrainern hoch professionell gehen die
miteinander um erfahre ich mit an Bord
darf ich trotzdem nicht aus
Sicherheitsgründen wie geht es den
Lotsen damit Exporte zu unterstützen mit
denen Russland seinen Krieg finanziert
hier geht es um Sicherheit nicht um
Politik für mich ist das ein Schiff das
um Lotsen bittet wenn ich mich
entscheiden würde als Lotse nicht zu
helfen und nicht für größtmögliche
Sicherheit zu sorgen sondern stattdessen
zu sagen ich mache das nicht wegen der
Politik und das Schiff läuft aufgrund
und Unmengen von Öl verschmutzen ganz
Dänemark dann hätte ich sicher das
Gefühl die falsche Entscheidung
getroffen zu haben
Mortens Heimat ist die Insel Bornholm
wie ein Flugzeugträger liegt sie mitten
in der Ostsee hier gibt es ein ständiges
Schaulaufen der Kriegsschiffe von
Russland und der NATO
ich treffe den Mann mit der wohl
spektakulärsten Aussicht auf die Ostsee
präben Biere ist Landwirt beunruhigen in
die Vorboten eines neuen Kalten Krieges
da draußen
nein Angst hatte ich nicht aber wir
haben schon ein paar mal erlebt dass da
draußen eine Menge Schiffe lagen das war
sicher weil die Sorge bestand dass da
etwas passiert
[Musik]
plötzlich wurde Bremen Teil dieser
Kriegsspiele als Russland immer mehr
Truppen um die Ukraine in Stellung
brachte wurde Dänemarks Militär
aufmerksam auf seinen Hof den ich
Offiziere vor und klopften an seine Tür
[Musik]
sie sind gekommen und haben höflich
gefragt ob Sie hier eine Radarstation
aufbauen dürfen ich habe kein Problem
damit also habe ich gesagt klar das
dürft ihr das war schon mehr ist nicht
passiert ich habe mir auch keine Sorgen
gemacht oder Fragen bestellt für mich
ist das ganz normal dass wir einander
helfen und aufeinander aufpassen soweit
das möglich ist
kurz vor dem letzten Winter haben die
Militärs ihre Installationen wieder
abgebaut warum ist Bremen völlig unklar
interessiert ihn auch nicht sein Feld
will er bald wieder in Ordnung bringen
in Dänemark lassen Sie sich vom
Machtpoker in der Ostsee offenbar nicht
aus der Ruhe bringen
für Schweden hat Neutralität immer
bedeutet sich notfalls auch wehren zu
können vielleicht ist es im Land deshalb
gelungen sich aus den letzten Kriegen in
Europa herauszuhalten doch nach
Russlands Einmarsch in der Ukraine war
es für die Regierung plötzlich fünf vor
Zwölf
wie Finnland will sich Schweden der NATO
anschließen
in den Scheren vor Stockholm sitzt
Schwedens geheimste Marinebasis alleine
kommen wir hier auf Muskeln nicht weiter
oberstleuttern Kinder zeigt uns was wir
filmen dürfen und was geheim bleiben
soll von ihm möchte ich wissen
verunsichert der neue Machtpoker in der
Ostsee Schwedens Militär
ung zu dem was wir tun hat sich
verschärft und das spürt man der Krieg
fühlt sich sehr nah an aber ich spüre
keine Unruhe ob das in Zukunft aber so
bleibt darüber macht man sich schon
Gedanken
weitaus größere Sorgen machen Sie sich
auf der 200 Kilometer entfernten größten
Insel Schwedens auf Gotland wegen der
strategisch wertvollen Lage mussten sie
sich in der Hauptstadt wispy schon immer
gegen Angreifer verteidigen
ich bin erstaunt wie unbeschwert ich die
Ostseeinsel erlebe auf Schwedens
Urlaubsinsel genießen Sie den Sommer
abseits dieser Ferienidylle hat sich
Schwedens Militär allerdings vorbereitet
Gotland zu verteidigen sollte die
strategisch wichtige Insel bedroht
werden es scheint vielen einfach
unvorstellbar dass man hier im Umfeld
der russischen Aggressionen in der
Ukraine zum Apfel werden könnte
ich habe kein Militär oder so etwas
gesehen ich merke hier nichts von
irgendeiner Bedrohung und muss uns
selbst ich persönlich bin nicht weiter
besorgt aber ich habe Kollegen und
Bekannte die ein bisschen Angst haben
weil in den Medien viel darüber geredet
wird
jetzt im Sommer wollen sie das Leben
genießen nicht ein Krieg denken doch
noch ein paar hundert Meter vom Strand
entfernt spüren Sie die Auswirkungen der
neuen Spannungen in Europa ingeler
betreibt einen kleinen trödeladen der
ist vor allem bei Urlaubern sehr beliebt
doch diesen Sommer so fürchtet sie
könnte der Laden oft leer bleiben der
Krieg hat den Urlaub teurer gemacht
Preise für Treibstoff Essen Heizung sind
auch in Schweden gestiegen
das Leben auf Gotland hat sich radikal
verändert es ist aber auch viel sicherer
geworden vor dem Krieg in der Ukraine
war die Unruhe greifbarer aber seitdem
das Militär wieder da ist fühlt sich
alles viel ruhiger an
ist einer von denen die jetzt Gotland
beschützen er ist Busfahrer und
chauffiert sehr viele Urlauber von
Kreuzfahrtschiffen über seine Insel für
ihn profitiert Gotland sogar vom
Machtpoker an der Ostsee
ist gerade sehr beliebt denn Kreuzfahrer
dürfen nicht mehr nach St Petersburg
wegen des Krieges das war letzten Sommer
auch schon
hat viele Jahre als Offizier bei
Schwedens Truppe gedient bei in
Friedensmissionen auf dem Balkan und in
Afghanistan jetzt sichert er nach
Feierabend den Frieden auf Gurtner
der verwandelt sich vom Busfahrer zum
Kommandeur der Heimwehr einem
freiwilligen Verband der landesweit etwa
die Hälfte der nationalen Streitkräfte
stellt
was passiert denn will ich wissen
sollten die Russen wirklich kommen
dann brauchen wir wohl Hilfe von anderen
Partnern von der NATO den USA England
oder wem auch immer dann brauchen wir
Hilfe denn Gotland ist sehr wichtig für
Schweden und für unsere Partner
dann reden wir von einem echten krieg ja
vielleicht
fürchten sie ein solches Szenario
nein sagt er das wird nicht passieren
denn Russlands Truppen sind ja gerade in
der Ukraine beschäftigt
es ist ein schwedischer Sommer nachts
Traum den sie hier leben offenbar völlig
unberührt von den Aggressionen ihres
mächtigen Nachbarn
Generationen sind in Schweden ohne Krieg
aufgewachsen machen sie sich denn keine
Sorgen dass es Ihnen vielleicht anders
gehen könnte
am Anfang hatten wir schon Angst dass
Sie hierher kommen könnten aber jetzt
beschäftigt mich das nicht mehr so sehr
ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen was
die hier eigentlich wollen
hoch über der Ostsee verdrängen sie
Russlands neues Macht streben aber in
diesem zweiten kriegsommer spüren sie
dass ich in ihrem Land etwas bewegt das
Ende von schwedensneutralität wird auch
ihre Zukunft verändern
[Musik]
diesen Zeiten vor allem weil Finnland
sich der NATO anschließt ist es ganz
normal für Schweden diesen Schritt auch
zu tun
ich sehe darin mehr positive Aspekte
aber es macht mir auch ein bisschen
Angst der ganze krieg ich hatte gehofft
junge genug zu sein um mich mit diesen
Fragen nicht beschäftigen zu müssen
in Schweden erleben Sie den Machtpoker
in der Ostsee so hautnah wie auf Gotland
und das mitten in einer so friedlichen
Kulisse wie dieser
im finnischen Grenzgebiet zu Russland
will ich sehen wie der neue Kalte Krieg
das Leben hier verändert die
Grenzübergänge sind nur noch tagsüber
geöffnet die Kontrollen scharf für die
Einreise gelten Beschränkungen
Alexandra aus Russland macht den
Finnland eine Ausbildung sie überquert
die Grenze regelmäßig
alles sehr kompliziert es ist mein
Heimatland dass ich sehr liebe und wo
ich aufgewachsen bin aber wenn man dann
nach Europa kommt ist das viel
friedlicher so fühlt sich das an
die finden waren stets wachsam wenn es
um die Grenze zu ihrem Nachbarn im Osten
geht
Hacker lebt schon sein ganzes Leben an
der Grenze er fährt mit mir raus zu
Carolina und ihrem Mann
die Fischer haben Reusen in Sichtweite
der Grenze ausgelegt ob sie ihren Fang
wohl noch nach Russland verkaufen können
ich glaube wir verkaufen jetzt gar nicht
mehr nach Russland
sie reden darüber wie Russlands neue
Aggressivität hier im Osten Finnlands
die Wirtschaft abwirkt
wie lange das andauern wird das wissen
wir nicht das weiß niemand von uns
die Grenze ist wieder eine Hürde das
spüren Sie hier in der Wirtschaft vor
allem im Tourismus
[Musik]
wie ein Raumschiff in den Tiefen des
Weltalls folgt die Camilla ihrem Kurs
auf dem cybersee bei La pelanda der
finnische Ausflugsdampfer fährt durch
die traumhafte Landschaft Süd Kareliens
bis zur russischen Grenze sind es nur
ein paar Kilometer für Kapitän ist es
der 49 Sommer auf dem See mit 15 hat er
angefangen als Schiffsjunge doch noch
nie hatte eine solchen Einbruch des
Tourismus in dieser Region erlebt je
nach Putins Angriff auf die Ukraine
denn wir sind ja so nah an der Grenze
die Russen kamen vor allem zum Einkaufen
in der Stadt hat man viel russisch
gehört jetzt hört man das nicht mehr
wenn wir früher vielleicht 2000
russische Passagiere hatten sind es
heute bestenfalls wenige hundert es hat
deutlich abgenommen Gruppen kommen gar
nicht mehr
diese Naturlandschaft war bei Urlauber
aus Russland sehr beliebt doch für die
meisten gelten seit Kriegsbeginn in der
Ukraine einreisesperren
darunter leiden auch viele Russen Anna
und Alexander aus Moskau hatten sich
hier einen Traum erfüllt vor einigen
Jahren haben sie Land gekauft und
Ferienwohnungen gebaut Urlaub in
frischer Waldluft waldbaden sozusagen
damit haben sie geworben
doch das Geschäft läuft schlecht er ist
die Pandemie jetzt der Krieg Personal
können Sie sich schon lange nicht mehr
leisten sie müssen alles selber machen
ihr finnischer Holz-
wenn ich mir das heute anschaue dann
würden wir das nicht noch mal machen
vielleicht irgendetwas anderes wegen der
aktuellen wirtschaftlichen und
politischen Lage und so
aber wir wollen schon hier bleiben und
irgendetwas anderes machen was besser in
unser Leben passt aber eher nicht noch
mal das gleiche denn dieses Projekt hat
ein paar Schwachpunkte
jetzt hoffen sie auf hitzeflüchtlinge
aus Mitteleuropa die in diesem
finnischen Wäldern einen kühleren Sommer
verbringen wollen not macht erfinderisch
das ist auch in diesem Supermarkt so
direkt an der russischen Grenze gibt es
hier Produkte speziell für Kunden aus
Russland die aber jetzt kaum noch reisen
dürfen
vor allem Angestellte schieben die
Einkaufswagen nun durch die rein denn
die Russen bestellen jetzt von zu Hause
per Internet
wenn ich das eingesammelt habe geht es
zur Kasse wird verpackt und dann kommt
eine Spedition aus Estland und fährt
alles nach Russland über die Grenze
der Umtausch russischer Rubel in Euro
läuft über eine Bank in Österreich und
kann jederzeit durch eine neue Runde
internationaler Sanktionen abgewürgt
werden
Inhaber Mohammed spricht jetzt schon von
bis zu 85% weniger Umsatz das Russland
den Krieg bald beendet bezweifelt
no no nein ich hoffe aber ich glaube
nicht dass ich diese komplizierte
Situation schnell löst
ich kenne die russische Mentalität ich
lebe ja in Russland weil meine Frau
Russin ist
sehr schwer dass die Russen aufgeben
von Ehre und von Unbesiegbarkeit sie
sind leidensfähig aber eine Niederlage
werden sie nie akzeptieren
[Musik]
und so bringt Russlands Krieg auch die
Wirtschaft und viel Geld keineswegs nur
russische Unternehmer auch in
lappenranda hängt Finnlands
Tourismusbranche an den Gästen von
auswärts die Russen fehlen jetzt hoffen
Gastwirte wie aja das ausgerechnet
finnlandsbeitritt zur NATO neue Kunden
bringt
questions
so dicht an der Grenze sind
da ist die NATO natürlich ein
Versprechen für Verteidigung und das
macht es jetzt wesentlich einfacher die
Leute zu überzeugen hierher zu kommen
der weitere zur NATO ist für Finnland
ein großer Schritt er bringt ein
Sicherheitsversprechen ins Grenzgebiet
zu Russland zu einer Zeit in der sich
hier viele Tore schließen
acht Schleusen sind es für Schiffe vom
zweimal Kanal bis ins Russische wieburg
an der Ostsee bis zum Einmarsch in die
Ukraine war das eine viel befahrene
Wasserstraße mit großer wirtschaftlicher
Bedeutung jetzt haben die schleusenwerte
nur leere Becken auf ihren Monitoren
wir haben jetzt sehr viel weniger Arbeit
denn es gibt ja keine Schiffe mehr am
Kanal alle wissen warum wir erledigen
die täglichen Routinearbeiten aber die
eigentliche Arbeit ist das
durchschleusen der Schiffe
das passiert jetzt nur noch in dieser
Schleuse direkt hinter dem sei mal See
es sind Ausflugsdampfer wie die Camilla
die gleich wieder drehen und Richtung
lappenrand hat zurückfahren vor dem
Krieg sind im Jahr etwa 1.500 Schiffe
durch den Kanal gefahren in diesem Jahr
noch kein einziges ständig in
Bereitschaft sind sie hier trotzdem
trinke Kaffee bewege mich ab und zu aber
es ist schwer nachts wach zu bleiben
wenn es keinen Verkehr gibt
die Fracht hat sich längst andere Wege
zur Ostsee gesucht viel wird jetzt über
den finnischen Seehafen Amina verschifft
Holzlatten aus Karelien zum Beispiel mit
Ziel Großbritannien die jetzt mit der
Bahn oder an Bord von vielen Lastwagen
ihren Weg hierhin gefunden haben
auch wenn der Krieg in der Ukraine enden
sollte so wird es sicher keine schnelle
Rückkehr des Verkehrs durch den
seilmerkanal geben es hat sich schon
viel verändert und normalerweise ist es
schwierig wenn neue Transportstrecken
gefunden wurden zu den alten
zurückzukehren
Kanal der einst Russland und Finnland
verbunden hat wird damit wirtschaftlich
langsam überflüssig das Leben an der
neuen Nahtstelle von NATO und Russland
ändert sich rasant
die junge Generation wächst auf in einem
veränderten Europa
Valerie hat gerade Abitur gemacht zum
Fotoshooting trägt sie stolz die Mütze
der Absolventinnen so ist es Tradition
auf den hollandinseln die 18-Jährige
möchte Architektin werden der Nahe Krieg
in Europa überschattet ihren Aufbruch
ins Erwachsenenleben
wir sind ein verwundbarer Teil Europas
weil wir in der Geschichte schon früher
wegen unserer Lage in der Ostsee
heimgesucht wurden klar reden jetzt alle
darüber dass die Russen kommen oder wie
man das sagen soll aber ich spüre keine
große Bedrohung ich finde es einfach nur
schade das ist immer noch Krieg gibt das
wäre es nicht besser gelernt haben
orlands das sind gut
6.700 Inseln und Scheren zwischen
Schweden und Finnland mitten auf der
Ostsee strategisch gelegen
früher gehörte die Inselgruppe zu
Russland der Zahl ließ eine gigantische
Festung bauen wollte von hier die Ostsee
beherrschen die alten Kanonen sind
stumme Zeugen vom Scheitern Russlands
Franzosen und Briten hatten die Festung
vor gut 170 Jahren zerstört der folgende
Friedensvertrag gilt bis heute auf den
Inseln darf kein militärstationiert
werden damit haben sie hier kaum eine
Chance sich zu verteidigen
nach über einem Jahr Krieg in Europa
will ich wissen wie verwundbar sind die
Inseln wenn die Russen kommen sollten
nur die Küstenwache kontrolliert was
sich rundherum auf der Ostsee tut
auf ihren Patrouillenbooten sind sie
hier verantwortlich für die Sicherheit
vizekommandant Juri nimmt mich mit auf
Streife jeder einzelne der orlandinsel
gehört zu seinem Revier eine Landfläche
knapp doppelt so groß wie Berlin mir
kommt das ziemlich unübersichtlich vor
es ist klar dass wir uns in der jetzigen
Situation ganz anders auf bestimmte
Aufgaben konzentrieren wie zum Beispiel
die Überwachung unserer Grenzen wo wir
jetzt ganz genau hinschauen
auf jede Veränderung in unserem
Seegebiet
an juri und seinen Leuten kommt
vielleicht keiner vorbei Kameras auf den
Scheren helfen Ihnen
Datenleitungen und Stromverbindungen
hier draußen zu schützen
immer öfter landet auch Russland auf
ihrem Radar
uns ist im Laufe der letzten Jahre
aufgefallen dass die russische Präsenz
in der Ostsee definitiv zugenommen hat
sowohl mit Kriegsschiffen als auch mit
zivilen Fahrzeugen
Soldaten und Kriegsschiffe haben hier
nichts zu suchen Finnlands Regierung hat
zugesagt nach dem NATO-Beitritt die
historischen Verträge zu würdigen über
deren Einhaltung auf den hollandinseln
sogar eine russische konsulatwacht
seit Putins Angriff auf die Ukraine
erleben Moskau aus Diplomaten hier jeden
Nachmittag
stimmengewaltigen Protest
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Tag für Tag stehen sie hier singen die
Europahymne es ist ihr Ventil für ihre
Wut ihre Ohnmacht
so falsch so falsch deshalb wollen wir
dagegen protestieren wir wollen sie
anschreien ich glaube zwar nicht dass
putinos hört aber wenn jeder in Europa
jeden Tag vor den Botschaften stehen und
schreien würde könnte das vielleicht
etwas bewegen
vielleicht können wir ja nichts
erreichen aber es ist eine Unterstützung
für alle hier lebenden Ukraine wir haben
viele Flüchtlinge hier 330 glaube ich
das ist immerhin ein Prozent unserer
Bevölkerung für die ist es doch wichtig
dass wir Sie unterstützen
sie erzählen mir dass der dem sie ihre
Wut entgegen schreien inzwischen oft vor
der Demonstration wegfährt gemeinsam mit
seiner Frau einer Ukrainerin
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich verabschiede mich von diesem
entrüsteten Insel edel vor Russlands
Haustür auf den orlands sind Sie wachsam
mein Eindruck nach dieser langen Reise
ist die Nordeuropäer haben Respekt
lassen sich aber nicht einschüchtern von
ihrem großen und neuerdings wieder so
aggressiven Nachbarn auf der anderen
Seite der Ostsee
Russland schottet sich ab das spürt man
auch im Baltikum man will den alten
Besatzer nicht zu nah an sich
heranlassen meine Kollegin Natalie
Steger hat mit Menschen geredet die
davon überzeugt sind Russland hätte das
Baltikum gerne zurück doch die Balken
bauen auf den Schutz der NATO genau die
verstärkt ihre Präsenz auf und über der
Ostsee mit Minen Tauchern und Kampfjets
zu sehen in der ganzen Dokumentation
macht Poker an der Ostsee